I think it's somebody who lives by their
own rules and doesn't necessarily accept
the dictates of society easily
um and is his own mental point of origin
to quote um roller tomasi there are
certain other things as well I mean some
physical prowess you know physical
fitness ability to maybe stop
subfighting training things like that
you know go go towards that archetypal
sort of masculine guy but I think
fundamentally what it comes down to is
being on your own path and not being
cowed by
Society exactly and and what others want
you to be and do and I think what we're
seeing now is a lot of people who a lot
of guys who actually are being killed by
society and they're going along with the
narrative or they feel the narrative to
be
I would say the same thing to be fair I
feel like a guy is just more practical
more able to give to let's say for a
female
um they have to have an ounce of like
gym in them or like doing something
masculine in society and just
intelligent I would say and obviously in
their own path like they don't really
listen to outside they're not really a
social Conformity did you sorry I'll go
around and ask a question later on
um I would say someone who is extremely
confident in the on purpose someone who
understands
um
the the goal is the um
the objectives is more important than
you are so you're willing to sacrifice
for the most time most of the time it
will be you for the purpose of the of
the aim or the goal of whatever you're
doing so it will be your family if you
be your country it could be your
community you are so if you're willing
to put your Yourself In Harm's Way or
for your community something like that
yeah
um just what's a masculine man someone
who is not feminine
I agree with everybody and I want to add
on to it someone who's a leader
um I think that's a very masculine trait
and people argue women can be leader
um not as well as men I would say and it
all boils down to if a man's not leading
in the household it's it's gonna crumble
and I think a guy who's not afraid to
speak his mind right because it's like a
breath of fresh air when like a guy
walks into a room and he's just like not
I don't I don't think that's right or
like he's not afraid to say what he
thinks right because as women like we
can feel when you're pandering to us
yeah like we just we could like feel it
in our soul or even when you have a
conversation with a woman and they're
just like yeah yeah agreeing with you
and it's like I want I want to have that
like pushback or want to have that
conversational but
but the thing is a lot of men don't
understand that that in the short in the
short term that works for a certain type
of woman so yeah you know the Derek
Jackson's of the world right and um do
you know I mean like those kind of guys
who Pander towards women it works for a
short space of time but essentially
women like masculine men you know I mean
and they respect them and so you know
I've said so many times this
um society and a lot a lot of the time
the feminist movement attempted to build
the type of man that women wouldn't want
yeah they always do that so what they've
done is that they said become more
feminine and be more in touch with your
feminine side I grew up in a time where
there was a you probably got the same
time these are called the metrosexual
yeah exactly remember that term the
metrosexual right yeah and that's like
what the hell is a Metro and that's when
women started to kind of effeminize men
and say oh men are supposed to be a
little more feminine to be in touch with
feminist side and I'm like you're
building the type of men that you
wouldn't even be attracted to why would
you do that yeah exactly well I drank
the Kool-Aid on that a little bit not
the much sexual thing but even slightly
before that that's that phrase
um uh get in touch with your phone and
inside it probably came from like the
80s maybe something like that and I
remember that phrase being it was around
in the in the Consciousness and um you
know early on I sort of believed it for
a bit I thought our women they want to
see you being vulnerable they want now
and then what you discovered that well
baby lion
in the harsh in the harsh gladiatorial
ring of dating is that if you show that
sort of vulnerability and weakness
um you'll you're gonna get kicked to the
curb right particularly early on I mean
maybe you get a bit more leeway if
you've been in a you know long-term
relationship but but even then you know
you've got to retain that masculine core
otherwise really your toast okay I have
a question for the girls okay he's a one
to ten he's a five but he's really
masculine what is he how many points
does that give a guy
she's a six but she's like super
feminine what is she she's my wife
it probably would actually give her
additional points because because people
think oh you know guys it's all about
looks blah blah blah obviously there's a
degree of Truth in that because we are
very you know physical you know look at
us just start somewhere yeah exactly but
same for women oh yeah you know when
you're traveling around and you meet
women who have very they are very
feminine and they are very pleasant and
and all that it definitely adds
something to it for sure oh definitely
yeah
oh sorry sorry go on I have a question
for the men
what like is that do you like your women
like submissive like she's not
independent because the way you said
nine it seems as if like you don't want
your your babe to do anything kind of
thing you know what I mean for me I'll
be honest like like he said he kind of
drank the Kool-Aid of the
yeah growing up I I like to think I was
relatively I'm very independent thinking
I just do what I wouldn't even say I'm
necessarily masculine one woman
described it to me um what's the word
when you're independent thinking you
don't really care like a sigma type
that's is it Sigma Sigma male is
something like that she said something
like that I never heard of that term
before when I researched I'm like yeah
this is kind of me I just do whatever I
want I don't really care what people are
saying anyway
in doing that I go over girl that I
liked and I pandered to her and I
thought you know what I'm gonna be a
nice guy I don't actually are horrible
and that just backfired in my like and
it didn't make no sense to me because I
was like I actually tried to be a nice
human being and she didn't like it and
she was but anyway so why don't you keep
listening to women don't listen to them
don't listen to them 100 do not listen
to them but going on to what you're
saying in terms of a woman is not if
she's feminine it's not that she
submissive in the way I think you're
thinking of it is more that
I look at it like less stress I just
look at it as like less stress so that
means like I'm not a horrible human
being so I'm not going to take advantage
of you and take the myth out of you but
if you are comfortable in your
femininity it just makes me want to do
more for you like it's such I always use
this as an example if you go back to um
when you was in school there's always
like a group of girls who are very loud
and very boisterous and very present
themselves to be masculine and they'll
always be a group of girls who are quite
girls are masculine yes yeah yeah and
there'll be a group of girls who are
quiet I always said if there was a fight
to ever happen I'm protecting the girls
who are quiet right just naturally
because I just feel like I have to
protect you because you're always louder
than all of this kind of thing I'm like
yeah let them deal with it yeah and I'll
protect the people that are quiet just
because something about them is telling
me that they need protection and I will
naturally gravitate to them and that's
just how it works I don't know how it
just happens like if your feminine I'll
just I just want to help you so so you
are so repeat your question again
um what makes a woman like so submissive
that it's just like yes like I don't
know I don't know I forgot you said you
said something along the line
um do you really want
to them yeah like do you want her like
dependent on you completely like she has
nothing kind of thing I I think a lot of
women
um misconstrue what submission is you
know I mean I think when you say that
the fact that you think submission is a
woman relying solely on her man and not
having any independence of her own it
kind of um
it speaks to the psychology of what the
term submission is for a lot of people
because I don't think submission is a
woman not having her own do you know
what I mean like women can have their
own and I think I think it's smart for
you to have your own yeah so um Auntie
had a really good analogy last time she
was here she was like even if a woman
works like I um oh there was like she
was describing a couple and she's like
yeah she would take her money from work
and hand it to her husband
because she's like you trust him with
your body how could you not trust him
with money like do you not think your
body is more valuable than money
so do you do you think you have a
different version of submission no
because I'm just I was just like as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible